georges rémi alias hergé vous êtes le
père d'un jeune garçon qui vieillit pain
en fait en apparence physique mise à
part tintin est il toujours le même en
1972 qu'en 1929 date a évolué évidemment
dans la mesure où j'ai évolué et moi
même mais fondamentalement il est resté
le même
il est resté un petit peu et scout je
crois que je suis resté un peu boy-scout
ci est de ce point de vue là donc il n'a
pas changé
du point de vue des saints il est
certain qu'il était qui je crois qu'il
est mieux dessiner maintenant qu'au
début il était vraiment très sommaire
alors je crois que j'ai fait quelques
progrès dans ce domaine là donc il est
le même mais mais mais mais il a vieilli
sans vieillir comment expliquez-vous le
grand succès qu'il a aux frais de gêne
un très large public
ça c'est un mystère pour moi au petit
jeu je constate qu'il a du succès c'est
vrai depuis longtemps ce qui m'étonne
encore davantage mais pourquoi je n'en
sais rien
est-ce que c'est peut-être parce que
chacun chaque enfant peut se projeter
lui-même là dedans
vous savez que l'on a fait un jour un
film un comédien
au début on a cherché le petit
personnage qui serait qui pourrait
incarner tintin et on a reçu une lettre
le producteur du film a reçu il a lille
une enquête il a il a posé la question
et il a reçu une lettre d'un petit noir
un jeune noir disant moi je pourrais
jouer tatin
moi je suis tintin il ne voyait pas la
différence de couleur oh il y la réponse
était d'identifier en fait à tintin et
c'est peut-être ça une des raisons du
succès mais les autres je suis vraiment
incapable de l'année c'est le deuxième
dessin animé que l'on va voir le lac aux
requins
après je crois tintin et le temple du
soleil quelle est votre participation
elle a surtout consisté à l'élaboration
avec
greg du scénario et ensuite dans les
décors il ya eu les modèles cheese aussi
un mot barbare qui signifie qu'on a
désigné les personnages de face de dos
de profils de trois cas de façon que les
animateurs puis s'en servir pour faire
leurs animations
ça c'est dans un premier point il a
fallu créer des personnages nouveaux qui
est ton qui ont été faits dans mes
studios
il a fallu faire les décors surtout
qu'ils ont été défaits également dans
mes studios
tous les corps ont été dessinés non pas
colorier mais destiné aux studios hergé
ç'a aidé ma participation
j'ai le père de tintin le père de tintin
en effet il y a il y aura exactement 50
ans dans cinq jours le 10 janvier 1929
en effet paraissait pour la première
fois les aventures de tintin tintin au
pays des soviets dans un journal
illustré pour les enfants catholiques
qui saturaient le petit vingtième je
crois comment alors est-ce que donc dans
cinq jours ce sera cet anniversaire est
ce que est ce que le 10 janvier 1929
vous avez eu conscience et le 11 ou le
12 les consciences du succès on présente
pas du tout pas du tout du tout du tout
c'était vraiment je considérais sac une
petite farce comme petites choses sans
lendemain pour promulguer des amis
c'était c'était pas plus que ça c'était
pas autre chose que c'est pourtant le
succès venu rapidement que oui mais un
petit succès dans un petit public
c'était un journal catholique c'était le
20e siècle joindre confessionnelles donc
dont le tirage devait être aux alentours
de dix mille exemplaires par jour ce
n'est pas vous mais le lait tout gros
tirages et il ya eu un gros succès oui
mais parmi un tout petit public
oui mais pourtant on raconte que à la
fin de de tintin au pays des soviets
quand intervient donc à bruxelles et
accueilli en triomphe
oui oui enfin voila c'était un petit
triomphe ou particuliers pour déranger
les gens dans une guerre oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai beaucoup d'indicés nous
risquions jamais dérangé père sébastien
chabal fait donc comme en question qu'on
a souvent dû vous poser mais cet
anniversaire du logis de la pause et
aussi à mon tour comment vous est venue
l'idée de ce personnage au fond quelles
sont les influences qui vous ont amené à
créer ce personnage de tintin le
reporter de 15 ans je crois que j'ai
toujours eu envie de raconter des
histoires et je les raconte et souvent
c'est pour ne pas les oublier les
illustrer quand j'étais déjà très très
très jeune
et puis après lorsqu'on m'a confié la
rédaction de ce petit supplément
illustré le petit vingtième parce que
d'un supplément de ce journal le 20e
siècle
j'ai donc pensé à faire une histoire
d'un petit bonhomme mais comme je savais
très mal décidé de signer très très très
mal et que je me disais que ça allait
tout même durer quelques semaines
g
je me suis contenté de faire un petit
rond à cercle petite mèche pour donner
un accent comme ça j'étais certain que
ce personnage on le reconnaît trait de
dessin en dessin et de semaine en
semaine
c'est vrai que le premier tintin qu'on
trouve dans le pays des soviets
on va nous le montrer tout à fait
différent de tintin qui est devenu
célèbre
oui par le croquis oui mais pourquoi
alors c'est tout pète je pensais plus de
programmes un accent pour pour qu'ils ne
soient pas tout à fait rond sinon il
aurait un cercle ça n'était pas
tellement reconnaissable 6 enfin il
fallait un petit accent à ça j'ai donné
mais où et pourquoi alors qu'il suit
milou pourquoi un chien mais parce qu'il
est pas bon que l'on soit seul pour il
faut voyager avec pour voyager je crois
qu'un chien c'est encore la meilleure
hannibal faisait difficilement de
voyager avec nous avec un téléphone avec
un chat difficile alors à chiens il y
avait un journal qui s'appelait ric et
rac bourse est nécessaire et le petit
chien c'est un espèce de fox terrier
comme ça mais qui est il de vous en
tintin ou de vous de ce que vous êtes de
ce que vous auriez aimé mais je crois
que qu'il s'agisse de romans ou qu'ils
s'agissent
de théâtre mais je crois que tout auteur
quel qu'il soit y compris un auteur de
bande dessinée se met lui-même se
projette sur sept personnages je crois
que tintin c'est une partie de moi même
qui aurait voulu être un héros qui
aurait voulu être à reporter comme vous
simplement commencer et puis c'est le
capitaine haddock avec mes colères mais
commerce vous êtes aussi l'équité nada
oui je suis tout ça je crois que vous
faisiez de la castafiore aussi parfois
ça y est vous les fidèles de lomé la
commune en avant ma faim non mais les
principaux personnages
je me retrouve en eux parfois je crois
que c'est vrai je crois que dupont c'est
moi oh oui aussi oui je connais donc
acheter des beti ça m'arrive de faire
des bêtises
alors c'est oui moi ce qui me frappe en
regardant les la liste des titres des
aventures de tintin c'est que c'est le
côté ses côtés au fond grand grand
littérateurs parce que vous avez fait
votre voyage en urcisse us si je ne m'en
mêle pas dans les dates avant gide à
l'est les rebelles étaient très loyal
vous avez fait votre voyage au congo
avant lui aussi ensuite vous avez fait
votre chine
juste avant juste après malraux en tout
cas juste après la célèbre émission
linden il y à il y a une espèce de
similitudes entre les grandes démarche
comme ça des grands intellectuels des
grands écrivains français ou de langue
française et les petites aventures de
tintin
ils précèdent toujours les gens
d'écrivain il est pressé de oui les
accompagnants fait en tout cas il est
dans l'air du temps et je manque c'est
cela ça c'est la nostalgie c'est la
nostalgie du dur dur évidemment pour moi
j'aurai dans un journal et pour moi leur
héros c'était l'europe et tina reportée
au début il a pris une plaie mais il a
écrit un article
oui mais vous avez contenu l'apéro porté
au oui nous apparaît plutôt comme un boy
scout redresseur de torts vous et comme
un policier qui veut rétablir l'ordre
aux quatre coins du monde mais ton nom
la venturi vient de chercher à domicile
plutôt et ne part pas sa rencontre
enfin et après
il va mettre de l'eau au fond gris il
met de l'ordre partout où il passe de
tintin en effet c'est juste il aurier il
est d'ailleurs et j'ai remarqué
plusieurs fois en relisant les tintin
qui avait fait le bonheur de la jeunesse
plusieurs fois des personnages qui sont
des méchants lui dise lorsqu'il est lié
qui va être exécuté jamais suivi chaque
fois vous avez la fâcheuse habitude
tintin de vous mêler de ce qui ne vous
regarde pas ça brison raison c'est à
présent toutes sortes de risques nous
regarde pas tout à fait raison mais au
départ l'aventuré venait me chercher à
domicile ou des farces
ce n'est pas lui qu'il se jette sous vos
débuts au début par vraiment comment
reporter il va vers les points chauds du
globe qui sont la russie à l'époque
console l'amérique et la chine et c'est
comme vous avez dit alors là il se mêle
de choses qui le regarde puisque cette à
reporter qu'est-ce qu'il a des défauts
tintin mais ce sont les autres qui en
ont pour lui je crois qu'il a
malheureusement pas il n'a que des
qualités n'a que des qualités sarkozy
mais même milou lui a déjà des défauts
parce que milou j'ai remarqué il est il
est gourmand oui il a peur alors que
tintin n'a jamais eu peur il a peur d'y
et des chats d'autre part il est parfois
même je me souviens plus conséquente un
tas au tibet ont ils emportent un met à
mal le alors oui ils préférent boulanger
l'a offert d'autres en plus en chopant
ça me choque c'est un peu le sens je
pense à melo a deux camps revanche lui
n'a pas dit mot que des défauts parce
qu'il est coléreux ils échoueront
abdominales ou par dominer à propos de
jour ou de nuit figaro magazine a eu la
bonne idée d'en faire le recensement il
est ce qu'ils sont très connus tonnerre
de brest
bachi bouzouk que marin d'eau douce
quelques sacs soit s'étonnant par
ailleurs espèce de fatma prise unique
espèce de loup garou à la grèce de
renoncules et comment ça vous revient et
celui-là crétin des alpes pour ya des
crétins c'est la traduction belge du
bois être du valais on a beau oui mais
ça c'est un phénomène est logique et et
haddock mais enfin c'est un ivrogne deux
communes étaient ils étaient un grand
hugo début leur teinte à une mére
influence sur lui une affluence
remarquable
le capitaine haddock a continué avant
tout en sentant whisky il n'est pas le
seul et est même plus tellement certain
qu'il a changé en fait on l'a remis dans
le droit chemin va voir la bouteille par
aucun pays n'a jamais protesté contre le
fait qu'un des personnages de tintin et
si les états unis n'étaient pas permises
c'était pas pérenne vous avez été
censuré oui j'ai été censuré du temps de
la prohibition
oui non après après après on pouvait
boire
chacun sait qu on voit très très peu au
numérique et on peut voir un petit peu
mais il ne faut pas montré qu'on avait
du plaisir est un taille haie de gauche
ou de droite
au début quand même de droite n'en est
sûrement sûrement ce moment c'est de
repartir d'un journal catholique
n'oubliez pas c'est un journal donc le
xxème siècle qui était
non seulement confessionnel mais aussi
je crois de directeur était un ami
personnel de mussolini c'est vous dire
la tendance de toute façon c'était
c'était à ce moment là c'était pas la
russie soviétique c'était les bolcheviks
de l'homme au couteau entre les dents
c'était les atrocités c'était les
brisures de cloches de l'enfer pour
massacrer des familles entières seydoux
le premier interpellé voilà voilà voilà
donc il est de droite et est ce que
enfin après il devient alors
anticolonialiste il devient petit à
petit il est venu ne viennent plus oui
la parlant de son évolution alors entre
les 50 entre tintin au pays des soviets
et puis le dernier tintin chez les
picaros il ya 48 ans bon qu'elles sont
en quoi tintin changé physiquement ils
changent pas si trading aussi il a des
pantalons oui google le changement et
c'est vrai un gros changement mais ces
changements là pour personne son moral
sont c'est très difficile à dire il ya
toujours au dresseur de thor c'est vrai
mais je crois qu'ils les voient moins le
monde en noir et blanc quand même il ya
les méchants ne sont pas tout à fait
méchants et les bons ne sont plus tout à
fait jour oui c'est un peu ça mais parce
que des détails le lotus bleu
mais en chine on le voit et il il
intervient dans une bagarre où il ya un
affreux bonhomme blanche procès
thakhuli et dans la défense et puis même
il se fait moraliste un moment jeudi a
dit un petit chinois qui la lui dit mais
non ne change tous les blancs ne sont
pas mauvais mais les peuples se
connaissent mal ça oui ça c'était là
c'était pour pour expliquer un petit peu
les rapports entre en train européen
occidental et oriental et puis voilà les
différences de conception il essaie de
montrer que les choses étaient comme ils
le disent les dupont et dupond c'est une
satire de la police où il fut pourtant
louis athane appartient pas la police et
laure non non non rien colistiers et
puis du poli pour gabardine
officiellement aboli sont vraiment alors
2010 en doublant qu'un cycle les jumeaux
et sont jamais plaints des policiers je
n'ai pas eu de non non et tournesol vous
moquer de la science entendu tous les
non au contraire je n'ai pas voulu aller
sur la lune lui avant tout non il est un
peu saoul il est un peu distrait mais ça
ne m'empêche pas d'avoir une brillante
idée de néant bien voulez oui j'avais où
j'allais oublier j'étais chargé d'une
commission et au four vous avez répondu
tout à l'heure c'est anne mes neveux qui
s'appelle stéphane et qui m'a dit c'est
d'abord ça lui paraissait fabuleux vous
rencontrer alors ça c'est plus sérieux
que la littérature et il m'a dit est ce
que tu osera lui poser une question je
dis oui il m'a dit que l'âge atteinte à
vous avez répondu c'est un reporter de
15 à ça mais apparemment c'est quand
même le seul point qui inquiète un très
jeune lecteur c'est cette permanence à
du personnage à travers le temps est
cependant il est difficile pour un
personnage comme ça devait faire
vieillir parce que s'ils vieilli va voir
maintenant il va avoir en deux ans il va
rencontrer les fils à se marier ou avoir
des enfants je suis l'artisan a pour mot
ce propos j'ai lu que la dent dans
fluide glacial une revue assez
irrespectueuse houleux
un épisode 1 faute 1 évidemment le
scandale du petit congolais où on
apprend que tintin qui a bien vieilli
on voit les dupont et dupond aussi
qu'ils sont des gens très chenu et il
semblerait que tu atteins effet un
enfant au congo il est fluide glacial
voilà et la caisse compenser ça c'est le
succès voici l'enfer de la drogue on
voit tintin on voit tintin se piquer
dans une prison a toujours un flic des
mines marc est toujours caché ça aussi
mais ça ne vous ça ne vous tente pas en
lui en le gardant son âge les moeurs
évoluent en ça ne vous tente pas un
garçon de 15 ans aujourd'hui ils tombent
amoureux il a il a des tentations
peut-être pas aussi grand oui c'est
évident c'est est-ce que c'est pas un
problème non pas du tout non jeu parce
que je crois que la raison en est bien
simple je crois quand j'ai commencé sa
gt je sortais du scoutisme jambes et on
y pense aux arrêts des gens de notre âge
mais c'est vrai à fait vrai et les spu
les scouts à cette époque là bas pour
les personnes de cet âge là les filles
montrent tout à fait différent oui oh
quand même les chefs des nous
réunionnais sur les chiffres moi je suis
plus avec vous un oui oui oui il a bien
sûr oui bien sûr et à cette époque là
vraiment c'était tout à fait séparé les
garçons d'un côté les filles de l'autre
vont certainement le voyage mais très
loin mais c'est une question est est ce
que le créateur n'est pas jaloux de ses
créatures je veux dire par là c'est que
bon tata il a 50 ans mais il est
toujours le même
vous avez aussi 50 ans de plus vous avez
un petit peu plus de 70 ans vous ne les
méritent pas si les téléspectateurs s'en
rendre compte
il n'empêche que vous avez un peu plus
de 70 oui et comme vous vous aviez fait
votre créature elle ne vieillit pas non
je suis pas jaloux mais il est possible
que ce soit une projection de moi-même
qui qui
espérer ne pas vieillir c'est impossible
enfin c'est peut-être cela
et puis je crois réellement que ces
personnages là ne peuvent pas vieilli je
me souviens en tout cas du véritable
chagrin que j'ai eu quand j'ai eu la
mort de d'artagnan de porto s'est dit
content de bragelonne
pour moi ça aurait dû toujours resté les
trompes de terre mais est ce que tu es
mort avec vous je crois que oui je crois
que c'est à dire qu'il durera plus de
tintin on fabriquera pas de tintin votre
atelier vous
mais oui mais ça c'est un groupe je
crois réellement vg d'excellents
collaborateurs ils font de très belles
choses et qu'il faut le font beaucoup
mieux que je ne pourrais faire moi même
mais je crois que à la base quand même
et malgré ça c'est malgré tout un
travail personnel et comme je vous le
disais en commençant tintin c'est moi
capitaine haddock c'est moins qu'un
autre le ferait peut-être mieux le ferai
peut-être moins bien le ferait toute
façon d'une façon très différente de moi
donc je crois qu'il vaut mieux que vous
avez lu août atteint certes oui mais pas
pas bosser missions autrefois voulions
dire qu'il avait un fils j'ai toujours
un fils qui était temps de rations du
vantail naturellement tous les livres
que l'on le htv lisait filet que je peux
dire que j'ai été sortir de là de
quelques 25 30 ans j'ai été nourri moi
aussi l'outil est bien entendu et
comment cela vous apparaît du 1er mai
figurez vous qu'à la lumière de michelet
viry j'ai pensé je me suis dit qu'il y
avait un côté finish les discothèques
justement un côté professeur tournesol
le le savant et ouyahia dans les dents
montherlant dans l'écart d'un de
montherlant
il parle de michelin et de la façon dont
michelet ce s'exprime sur les femmes
notamment
il lit ce nigaud niche l'est pour de
choses évidemment tu parais ça un peu
ridicule ce nigaud de michelet ce qu'il
faut ce que ne dirait pas de
châteaubriant par exemple on peut aimer
ou ne pas aimer chateaubriand mais
chateaubriand ne lira jamais le nigaud
on peut dire ce nigaud
mais on peut dire également ce nigaud de
professeur tournesol
ce qui est à la fois risible et charmant
et charmant c'est ce côté ce que des
naïfs du savant qui est en même temps un
peu enfantin alors c'est à ça que vous
pensez en venant ici je pensais que
tournesol était une un nouveau type de
michelet c'est à dire le savant qui d'un
côté touchant de l'autre côté ridicule
mais ça va quand même quand même temps
est encore en hausse concerne leur vie
sans qu'il me semble toujours membre on
ne sait pas quel succès à voir en
angleterre je lave ou je ne sais pas je
crois que je crois qu'il est assez grand
mais je j'avoue qu'en en ce qui me
concerne la première fois que j'ai eu
contact avec des pincettes
il ya quelques semaines quand j'ai
commencé à voir les albums assez souvent
vous avez lu d'eau pour l'émission c'est
ça qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous à
une lecture tout neuf et bien il y en a
qui semble terrillon rétro par exemple
la chine
je me suis bon budget bleus s'est aperçu
oui que c'est quand même très très vieux
jeu congo aussi un langage cru liseret
visuel que l'année on dirait même de ses
kokoïty bongo s'est passé colonialiste
qu'en wi fi dont il y en a bon sens il
ya des choses que maintenant et ça me
rappelle un peu
vous avez sûrement connu ces livres
d'enfants où il ya un capitaine bigot
rose un anglais qui est un héros de la
de l'aviation anglaise du temps la
première guerre mondiale
eh bien ces avions sont toujours des
avions de la première guerre mondiale ne
vieillissent pas et et les vôtres non
plus finalement est ce que est ce que
les gens sont comprennent qu'il s'agit
d'une chine d'il ya très très longtemps
je ne sais pas qu'est-ce que vous n'avez
pas elle est ce que vous voulez pas
faire une espèce de tintin poste mao par
exemple non non mais je crois que les
légères fait deux-trois remake par
exemple il noir ça ça se passait en
grande bretagne je leur fais avec
d'autres avions d'autres d'autres
appareils d'autres trains afin de mettre
dans un décor plus typiquement
britannique
mais je crois que les lecteurs semblent
en tout cas ne pas ne pas se rendre
compte de ce côté rétro qui reste vrai
qui est cette année on remarque le géant
de bolloré fait à malraux en existe un
teint c'est moi même interprété comme un
certain humour moi je trouve que de
gaulle c'est un teint plus mille ou plus
haddock
oui mais c'était pas tellement mal euros
à 7 à 10 malraux voilà les syllabes red
wings
il a pas de te fais 10 à 2 où il a dit
je n'ai qu'un seul rival c'est tintin
jeudi à l'international refait dire fait
dire en tout cas c'est ça mais vos deux
chefs-d'oeuvre sur les vous avez 22
albums publiés
23 22 23 chez canon pas bon pour moi là
vraiment c'est qu'ils aient tous lui
c'est c'est le secret de la licorne
suivi du trésor de rackham le rouge
l'exotisme simplement c'est parce que
d'abord on voit apparaître le château de
moulins les bus on voit apparaître aussi
dans ces tournesols je crois qu'à paris
oui oui évidemment on voit vraiment
toute la galerie de portraits laquelle
est à petit
mais on vient de parler de des femmes on
vient de parler de dieu mais tintin et
vous avez dit qu'il est né dans un de
madère catholique
il ne parle jamais du ne va jamais à la
messe mais non c'est vrai ça pourquoi je
n'en sais rien je ne sais pas je crois
que ça ralentir l action ah bon c'est
que ça va avoir des aventures vraiment
extraordinaire dans une église dans une
abbaye ça me paraît difficile
seulement j'ai vu la présence de dieu
dans un volume c'est tintin au congo il
y avait re la fin rien d'horrible
méchant qui est qui et bouffer par les
crocodiles et châtiment juste de
châtiment et tintin sur la berge dit
dieu ait son âme est attrayant on
s'aperçoit qu'il a une chrétienne mais
c'est comme un peu bizarre que ces
personnages qui est née vraiment qui a
été suscitée par les prêtres mais qui
vous l'ont demandée et qu'il n'ait
jamais je trouvais juste on l'a parfois
demandé donc intervenir la divinité
c'est vrai lui et jamais je ne les fais
peut-être cette fois là mais une seule
fois peut-être parce que je ne sais trop
facile tintin étant dans une situation
difficile
mon dieu s'il vous plaît faites que je
sois sauver il est sauvé c'est un peu
facile pour le sauver en noir je suis
venu à ce moment c'est moi qui suis dieu
il n'y a pas de mission si malheureuse
en dos au congo il ya un missionnaire où
il y avait un faux missionnaire oui
c'est le côté rétro plus
il ya eu des missionnaires au congo
jusqu'à très récemment jusqu'à ce que
moi vous tous les métaux et unité et
puis alors les femmes aussi bon
évidemment commune à 15 16 ans non moi
je trouve que c'est un univers où ça n'a
pas sa place je trouve c'est vraiment
celle ans vous faites c'est l'anti
michelet parce que non seulement bon
teint s'intéresse pas au fameux peut
comprendre parce que pour aimer drame il
n'y a pas de femmes donc s'il y en a il
y en a mais sont des caricatures en
sorte qu'il y avait quelques fioles il
ya une concierge par ci une dame qui est
qui téléphonent qui téléphonent me
longtemps mais c'est tout oui je n'aime
pas de caricaturer les fameux je n'aime
pas si c'est une jolie femme et que je
la caricature c'est plus de jolies
femmes
alors ça devienne castafiore et vous ce
sage non je n'ai pas de je ne suis pas à
l'aise pour faire des dessins de faim
caricature le prochain tintin c'est
quand il faut deux ans de travail
oui bien merci alors d'autres livres si
vous voulez en savoir davantage sur sur
rgb vous pouvez lire tintin et moi
entretien mais qu'hergé par uma sadoul
aux éditions casterman et d'ailleurs je
soutiens que tous vos albums sont
publiés aux éditions casterman alors
tintin avec un journal publié un numéro
spécial pour votre 50e anniversaire
la saison de dessinateurs vous rendre
hommage en hommage à tintin
là par exemple il ya le premier montre
hélas le maurice qui a fait l'auteur de
lucky luke l'iran là on voit lucky luke
faire sauter tintin et milou dans un
dans une couverture avec les dalton à
côté et puis je trouve que les cahiers
la bande dessinée publiée un spécial
hergé et puis de vous l'histoire de
l'automobile des origines à 10,900 pas
de 1900 aujourd'hui des origines y
sommes depuis les origines alsaciennes
les laisse absolument superbe dans êtes
un spécialiste de l'automobile ne sommes
pas spécialistes
non mais enfin je me suis intéressé à ça
l'a été avec des collaborateurs l'ont
fait c'est cet album on a fait des
albums aussi sur les chemins de fer sur
les bateaux toujours sous cette forme là
aussi chez septimus édition